ideally parents let their children learn
how to help themselves
parents who neglect their children or
those who are overly involved achieve
the opposite
their children often learn helplessness
and hence believe that they can neither
control their life nor change their
environment
learned helplessness was first
discovered by two researchers who
conditioned dogs to endure electric
shocks
Martin Seligman and Stephen F Meyer
conducted their experiment with three
groups of dogs
from the first group were caged and made
to wait for a period of time before
being released these dogs were what's
known as the control group
second group were also caged and got
electric shocks From Below when they
pressed a button the shocks stopped they
learned that they could stop the pain
the third group of dogs were exposed to
the Sharks but had no way of stopping
them
after the conditioning all three groups
were put into a box that gave shocks on
one side but not the other
the first and second group of dogs
quickly learned to avoid being shocked
by jumping over the wall that separated
the two sides of the box
the third group of dogs made no attempt
to avoid the sharks they had developed a
cognitive expectation that they could
not avoid the pain Seligman and Maya
attributed this to learned helplessness
children can also be affected as this
oversimplified story attests
this is the story of Joe while other
kids were allowed to run this cute
little boy was put in a walker so he
couldn't hurt himself
and so from early on Joe learned that
the world is a dangerous place
on the rare occasions that his father
was home he told Joe to toughen up and
become a strong boy
but without a role model Joe lacked the
motivation to live up to his dad's
expectations he began to feel inferior
over time this feeling got stronger
Whenever there was a problem his mother
would jump in to help
Joe began to internalize the belief that
he couldn't help himself when confronted
with challenges
whenever he had to make a major decision
he'd ask his mum for advice
deep inside he resented her for not
allowing him to become more independent
what are your thoughts how can we help
those that failed to see the path out of
their toxic life how can we help them to
help themselves share your thoughts and
your own experiences with learned
helplessness in the comments below
foreign
if you found this helpful check out our
other videos and subscribe if you want
to support our work join us on
patreon.com sprouts for more information
and additional content visit
sproutschools.com